[Musique]
Anne de Bretagne ça vous évoque quoi
en France je crois qu'elle vient de
Nantes alors Anne de Bretagne moi je
connais le château d'Anne de Bretagne à
Nantes je connais ouais enfin non je la
connais pas personnellement mais je suis
de Nantes donc on connaît le château
politique elle était reconnue pour ça
d'ailleurs elle a été mariée à deux rois
et je pense que
c'est donc la place des femmes vous en
pensez quoi et ben je pense que elle
pourrait peut-être être un peu plus
représentée et un peu plus mise à
l'honneur pour tout ce qu'elles ont fait
dans l'histoire
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue à
Blois à deux pas du château rue Anne de
Bretagne vous allez voir qu'entre Anne
de Bretagne et la région Centre Val de
Loire c'est une longue histoire
[Musique]
cette jeune duchesse de Bretagne fille
de François II lui succède à l'âge de 11
ans faute d'héritier mal
elle quitte très vite la cour des ducs
de Bretagne pour rejoindre ces deux
époux dans leur résidence royale en
région Centre-Val de Loire
de France après une invalidation de son
union avec Maximilien et des épousailles
avec Charles VIII son enfance et son
adolescence sont un passage tourmenté
entre politiques et mariage très investi
dans la culture elle a été un mécène
engagée qui se devait de respecter
dignement sa terre-natalement
de Charles VIII et vient s'installer
avec sa cour à Blois elle décédera en
1514 au château de Blois berceau de la
Renaissance ou les pierres conservent
les secrets de cette reine unique
[Musique]
nous allons à la rencontre de Bérénice
tarcher blaisoise et captivé depuis
l'enfance par les châteaux et l'histoire
cette passionnée de sa région natale
m'attend pour partager avec nous
l'influence qui a eu sur la ville de
Blois cette grande reine de France a été
Anne de Bretagne
Bérénice merci de nous accueillir ici
dans la cour du château de Blois
qu'est-ce qui selon vous distingue Anne
de Bretagne des femmes de son époque
Anne de Bretagne est une femme un petit
peu particulière tout d'abord par le
fait que c'était une femme qui était
absolument convoité de tous et
finalement c'est une femme qui était
vraiment exceptionnelle par son
caractère et aussi par son envie de
faire vivre son duché de Bretagne
qu'elle aimait tant et finalement quand
elle a été mariée au roi Charles VII ça
a été un vrai traumatisme pour elle de
devoir céder la Bretagne au roi de
France par son mariage et vous quel
regard vous posez sur les femmes d'hier
d'Anne de Bretagne à aujourd'hui pour
pour le coup entre les femmes d'hier et
aujourd'hui il y a quand même un petit
fossé à l'époque fallait faire quand
même attention au niveau du statut vous
aviez pas la même vie si vous étiez une
femme de campagne ou si vous étiez une
femme de la haute société donc je dirais
quand même que les femmes de l'époque
dan de Bretagne elles ont du s'imposer
en politique ça n'a pas été évident mais
elle s'y est bien illustrée pour le coup
pour un de Bretagne et il est vrai que
aujourd'hui la position des femmes a
beaucoup beaucoup évolué je pourrais pas
dire que ça n'a rien à voir mais je
dirais que c'est une continuité il était
grand temps mais on arrive à avoir une
vraie liberté nous pouvons exercer notre
propre métier ça c'est une vraie
réussite on a encore beaucoup de choses
à faire donc on verra encore peut-être
dans 40 ans à reposer cette question et
le rassemble tout encore évolué merci
beaucoup et ben voilà des femmes d'hier
des femmes d'aujourd'hui des femmes
toujours des femmes encore des femmes
voilà et puis surtout n'oubliez pas des
fleurs
des cœurs des couleurs du bonheur même
pas peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]